all right pittsburgh steelers
they will have for 56 seasons three
coaches because mike tomlin extended by
three years beyond a contract that was
going to expire after this season he's
now under contract through 2024 that was
announced yesterday out of the blue by
the steelers i like how they handle
their business no leaks no five minute
heads up oh i'm sure that chafes the
guys out there who whose existence and
identity is premised on letting us all
know five minutes in advance of the
announcement that's about to come
stealers just drop it on twitter we have
a contract extension with mike tomlin
through 2024 and there it is and it
really is amazing chuck noll bill cal
amazing mike tomlin back to 1969 an
amazing run of stability easy to do when
the team is good if the team wasn't good
you know before 1969 they they had a
revolving door right at steelers
headquarters they had a lot of coaches
come and go because they stunk once you
start getting good and staying good it's
a lot easier to keep the same coach in
place for a long long time chris getting
good staying good finding three men that
in my opinion got a lot of similarities
that's the other thing that you know you
could talk to the rooney's about they
found a little formula as far as the man
they like
to lead their football team and the
players on that team and do all that you
know that's where you know chuck noll
bill cower mike tomlin no nonsense from
any of those guys in your face this is
what it is we gotta be tougher you know
all the all the cool sayings like we
were talking about yesterday you know
it's it's we want volunteers not
hostages there's just no bs with any of
those three guys and that's what mike
tomlin is so
this is well deserved it really is this
is one of the the better coaches in all
of the nfl there's in my opinion no
better person to manage personalities
communicate motivate a football team
mike tomlin is special that way i've
witnessed it before
it's been an unbelievable run with the
pittsburgh steelers so far i don't want
to say unbelievable okay maybe that's a
little too much but it's been really
really good that's for sure and i think
this was a no-brainer
a no-brainer a guy that hasn't missed
the playoffs
more than two years in a row and he's
been doing this or what this is going
into year 15 as the head coach so
uh
you know pretty special guy here and and
i'm glad to see it you know get done for
for his sake and for the steelers
yeah and
one of the things i hear all the time
from other coaches is
how mike tomlin
is so effective at
getting the most out of a player getting
a player who otherwise with another team
may be a very different guy right
problem a guy that's hard to handle a
guy that's hard to motivate a guy that's
hard to communicate with a guy that's
hard to get the most out of tomlin can
do it and when some of those dealers
players go elsewhere and the most
notorious example obviously obviously is
antonio brown but there have been others
and i'm not going to name names because
i don't want to trash those guys but
there have been others who have gone
elsewhere and their coaches are like oh
my god i had no idea that this guy was
this big of a pain in the ass right and
that's that's because mike tomlin
was able
to get him and keep him focused and get
those guys to come together and get more
out of the 53 players on the roster than
they individually and collectively would
otherwise produce the his best coaching
was 2019 when you lose ben
roethlisberger week two and your options
are mason rudolph and devlin hodges
and you still almost make the playoffs
that
that is is as impressive as anything
else mike tomlin's done and he still
hasn't had a losing season since he
became the head coach in 2000 that's
right i mean not one losing season i
mean eight and eight nine and seven is
the floor with mike tomlin and
you know every few years it's like whoa
we might be one of the better teams in
football can we make a super bowl run do
all of that he gives the organization
great flexibility i mean not not only is
he a great leader and a coach and
everything we've talked about that way
you know he he is
a great life teacher in a lot of ways
that's the one thing i always rubbed off
on me and just how to handle yourself
the energy you bring to the office the
everyday you know no excuses you know
don't blame others blame you know blame
yourself look in the mirror that's mike
tomlin and then he gives the front
office the flexibility too because of
what you just talked about
oh this guy's got a checkered history
it's a little bad uh he's a little bit
of a renegade ah who gives a crap mike
tomlin will get him in order we don't
really have to worry about that he knows
how to make it happen so they don't have
to like nitpick about guys sometimes and
their their background of their
personality because they know mike
tomlin has got the players in the locker
room you know in the right way and that
they'll you know take care of this new
guy who might have you know one or two
issues in his background and they'll
make it work and that's that's to me
what is really special about mike tomlin
let alone you know like something you've
talked about a lot before mike i mean
the steelers are relevant every year
every year even the years where they're
bad
which is eight and eight they're still
like damn they're good whoa they're a
pain in the butt oh they had a few
heartbreaking losses and that's how they
missed out on the playoffs right i mean
there's a lot of that we saw them a few
years ago not make the playoffs and you
know they got hot at the end of the year
right and they were playing with the
best teams in football beat new england
when they came into town do all of that
so his teams always answer the bell and
they always play tough and physical and
i think that's the thing that the rooney
family and the pittsburgh fans should
always get behind with mike tomlin and
he's not gonna he's not gonna bs you
you're always gonna know where you stand
with him
the problem for tomlin and the steelers
is that the standard is so high whenever
they hit a rough patch
you will hear
from the steelers fans that want to get
rid of mike tomlin i have a good friend
who that that that's up
oh god when are they going to get rid of
tom it's like do you do you really want
to see what it's like
post tomlin
and do you want to see what whoever
immediately hires mike tomlin becomes
because
you know every once in a while you'll
you'll see a guy get fired and land on
his feet immediately somewhere else adam
gase
fired by the dolphins landed with the
jets eric mangini when he got fired by
the jets landed with the browns look
tomlin would not be out of the building
before his phone would be ringing
definitely with an owner on the other
line i i could picture it if it ever
happens you know you you fill up your
box and you're making the walk to the
parking lot and the phone starts ringing
and it's insert name of owner who
happens to be looking for a coach or
maybe isn't looking for a coach
currently but now that mike tomlin's
available that owner will be looking for
a coach that's what would happen folks
and look chris a few years ago and i
think it was in the aftermath of the
antonio brown yeah that year was in the
locker room they beat the chiefs and
he's broadcasting on facebook right the
idea that that tomlin couldn't control
his guys people not realizing how well
he is controlling them right and every
once in a while some of it leaks out
there were members of the limited
partnership that were agitating
art rooney to change owners and art
rooney fortunately for tomlin the
steelers doesn't pay attention to the
limited partners and that's one of the
problems of being a limited partner you
really don't have a voice you can you
can try to exercise it but they're not
going to listen to you and again
fortunately for the steelers they
haven't listened and and i think that
mike tomlin has gone a long way to
covering up some of the flaws
talent-wise
because he gets them better than what
they otherwise would be gets them better
you know is able to be creative and do
different things that way
you know like we've talked about too
yeah they might lose games but there's
very rarely do you look at a game with
the steelers and go man they weren't
physical man they you know they didn't
play hard today that almost never comes
up he embodies the steelers like
embodies them i mean just as far as what
he stands for and what the steelers have
stood for ever since i've known them and
like to your point about you know
yeah i don't know there did there seems
to be and maybe you could remember this
maybe i was too young
right but like i i do feel like you do
there where when things get you know
whoa we're gonna go nine and seven and
eight and eight with mike tomlin it's a
little bit like hey your butt's on the
hot seat
and i just don't remember those
conversations coming up quite as quickly
with like bill cower and underwhelming
years and things like that i don't get
that and maybe maybe i'm wrong maybe i
was a little too young and you know
middle school high school to remember
exactly that those years but what do you
want to say go ahead
cower had three straight non-playoff
seasons right and there was never a
sense that he was in it that's what i
mean that's what i thought okay good
right but but but
look they didn't fire chuck noll
and i'm choosing my words here carefully
he's a hall of fame coach he's one of
the greats of all time they didn't fire
him but they were ready to move on they
showed him the door a little when he
went when when he retired at 58 i
believe and it's amazing to me still
that there wasn't a second act for chuck
knoll but there was kind of a sense and
i've been in around pittsburgh my entire
life there was a sense that the game had
started to pass in by that the window
had closed that one for the thumb that
they thought they were going to get in
1980 where a decade plus removed from
that quest to add to the four rings that
they won in relatively short order in
the 70s there was a sense that that
whatever magic it was
that he had captured in turning that
team around
was dissipating right and and uh if
anything they may have kept chuck noll
longer than they should have i remember
1989 they got beat by the browns 51
nothing out of the gates they somehow
made it to the playoffs that year but
um
it was time and they don't typically
fire people
but but they find a way to move on when
the time comes and chuck knoll when he
left
there was a sense that they were ready
to move on cower cower left on his own
power right the steelers were ready for
him to leave and i still think cower
left because he knew the steelers were
never going to pay him what he thought
he should get paid because he saw what
mike holmgren was making in seattle and
i think when cower retired his initial
thought was sit out a few years then
come back and get market value somewhere
else and then he realized hey you know
this tv gig is pretty good you still get
paid pretty well and you don't have to
you don't have to live in torment every
week right but uh yeah coward they
wanted to keep and tomlin's been there
ever since and tomlin's what late 40s
tomlin could be there another 20 years
or longer definitely i mean there's no
doubt yeah i'm going to say you're right
it's probably late 40s now right with
mike t
uh but
the energy in which he has
yeah i don't see you know any end you
know in in the near future that's for
sure i i don't think he loves this
you know again he really does it it
always
mike he was one of those guys and
there's a few in my career but just one
when i was down there in tampa with all
those great coaches and everything
you know and and you could i think even
if you asked you know my buddy kyle
shanahan he'd feel the same way whenever
we looked at mike tomlin we thought he's
going to be a head coach he's going to
be a head coach it's just a matter of
when you know where
and how how recent or how how quickly is
it gonna happen because he just had a
way with the defensive players i mean
it's really i mean the secondary guys i
mean i'm telling you he could have put
little crumbs in his hand and been like
here you guys go come on come and eat
come and eat and they would have been
like you know they'd have pecked out
it'd be like okay coach i'll do it sure
i mean he he's just got a magical way
about him that way you know with players
coaches everything and it kind of
radiates through the building and i
think that's why
i think it's a big reason why
that they don't really ever fall asleep
at the wheel as a football team because
i think when he busts through the doors
in the morning it's like let's go
football time and he's got everybody
getting going and going in the right
direction and you know there's of course
a lot a lot of value to to what you
bring into the office on a daily basis
too
the buccaneers of that era when you were
part of the team and really throughout
the gruden years and i don't know who
was setting this policy they were
notorious for not allowing position
coaches to go elsewhere to become
coordinators right affected rod
marinelli it affected mike tomlin when
tomlin finally had his contract expire
and was able to leave to become a
defensive coordinator it took one year
one year before people figured out this
guy
should be a head coach and i can
remember in 2006
when brad childress was the head coach
of the vikings and mike thomas was the
defensive coordinator i remember
thinking a few times that year
should we make it
backwards yeah yeah right
they may gotten this backwards folks and
then after tomlin left i had that
thought a lot more often uh about brad
childress sorry brad didn't mean to
throw you under the bus today but hey uh
head coaches get praised and bad coaches
or mediocre coaches don't but tomlin has
been great tomlin went into pittsburgh
and remember he was a master of the four
three the tampa two what did he do yeah
wait a minute i just got this three four
defense we don't we're we're i perhaps
i'm not gonna change what works i'm
gonna take what we have and i'm gonna
make the most out of it and two years
later they win the super bowl if he had
tried to change everything around and
put in a 4-3 like plenty of coaches
would have done right what did we see in
dallas this year yeah you don't have the
personnel right it's a transition it
hurts you he didn't do it and he has a
super bowl trophy to show for it mike
it's it's an amazing point by you and it
really it shows you again the leader and
the guy and that you know his ego didn't
get the best of them he doesn't think he
knows it all he was able to go there and
go wait this defense has been good since
you know florio was a little kid in 1972
like what you know i mean i think he
looked at it and realized hey the
blitzberg some of these coaches are here
it's been successful hey let's just keep
doing what we're doing and i'll add my
two cents and we'll tweak as we go and
that that is special you're right i i
mean really i don't think there's many
coaches that would have done that and
it's the defensive coach that goes there
after bill cower probably would have
tried to make his mark and this is what
we're going to do he realized it's a
strength of the organization it's a
strength of the scouting department to
find big d lyman and linebackers and do
that so why not keep things rolling the
way they are and he adjusted instead of
trying to make everybody else adjust and
i mean come on just the way he started
off his career taking over for a legend
like bill cower you know goes 10-6 gets
to the playoffs and like you said the
next year goes and wins the super bowl i
mean that's that's not easy in itself
and like we've talked about been really
good ever since
and let's not forget
the reality that
he almost didn't get the job
russ grimm was getting that job one of
the pittsburgh newspapers the tribune
review reported that grimm was getting
the job and it wasn't fake news they
were told
that grimm was getting the job right
however the dominoes fell behind the
scenes to change it from grimm to mike
tomlin i i think it's safe to say
russ grimm would not have gotten an
extension yesterday for three more years
i don't think it would have happened i i
he wouldn't have lasted that long and
and that's the thing about the steelers
to remember
it's easy to have three coaches since
1969
when you're winning
as long as you're relevant as long as
you're better than not more often than
not right it's every team would love to
do it well
you've got to have a good enough team
because eventually people aren't going
to show up if you stink year in and year
out eventually the waiting list in
pittsburgh for season tickets is going
to dissipate eventually those yellow
seats are going to be conspicuous
because they're empty that will happen
and when you look back through the
history of the steelers they had
they had a bunch of different coaches
they had three coaches from 1964 through
1968.
buddy parker was fired after the 64
season mike nixon lasted one year he
went two and 12. bill austin was there
for three years three coaches from 64 to
68 three coaches since
1968 when they hired chuck noll in 1969.
it if you're winning you can do that
that's the key if you stink you can't do
it no you you exactly right exactly
right and like here's the other thing i
just i i want to hit on i know we
probably got to go to a break here soon
or something like that but like you know
i always hear like the um oh
you know mike tomlin they they kind of
always under achieve you know there in
pittsburgh you you hear that a lot and
i'm gonna go
why wh what what what tells you that
they should win the super bowl like to
you
when you hear that
like does that ring true like for me it
does not there's one year i can look at
where i went
pittsburgh should have been better or
gone deeper in the playoffs other than
that
you know i haven't looked at it that way
at all yeah that year they lost to
jacksonville and tomlin said that the
you know the clash between him and the
patriots and the af was gonna be awesome
and all that type of stuff
that's the only year i can i really
remember at least where i went oh
you know they were a super bowl team
they might have been the best team in
football that year and they kind of
dropped the ball and fell asleep at the
wheel in the divisional playoff game but
other than that i just i think that's a
bs narrative i don't know how do you
feel about that
p p just mentioned the tebow wild card
playoffs well from 2011 when basically
they dared tebow to beat them and he did
well
they they did they dared it but any and
it worked they did it damaris thomas 80
yards walk off see you later right but
the other part of that context too and
people need to realize this like this is
where this matters yeah that looks at
top like base level like it was an upset
it was an upset steelers were 12 and
four that year the broncos were really
damn good i mean we know that if they
had a good quarterback they were a super
bowl team too there's a reason they
shipped him out the door right when the
season's over but like here's the other
aspect where i because i had a
pittsburgh friend say that to me through
text
and i just went yeah but do you remember
big ben could barely walk he was he
played and limped into the playoffs he
was not himself in that playoff game he
played bad in that game himself you know
tomlin's cool that way he let his you
know big soldier captain of the offense
go out there and play it like 60 70
percent you know so that was a big part
of why they lost that game too just to
defend that but yeah that would probably
be the other loss people look at to go
they shouldn't have lost that
i wonder how many more super bowls the
steelers would have won over the course
of the past 15 years if the patriots
weren't the patriots right because right
the steelers have not fared well against
the new england patriots and ultimately
the patriots caught them
at six they're tied at six both teams
trying to get the number seven wanting
to break that tie but you know i i
remember
how jarring it was when mike tomlin
after the season opening game 2015 right
had the issue with the radio it's always
something when we come to fox but there
was some of that frustration yeah and
his inability to beat bill belichick
coming through because i think he knew
that that
you know you know that stuff happens and
it was raining that night and there was
a reasonable explanation for it and we
know the nfl
not inclined to accept the reasonable
explanations of new england patriots so
if they accepted that one it must have
been true but but i i think that that
belichick and the patriots have been
an achilles heel he's found the achilles
heel for the pittsburgh steelers because
maybe they would have
seven or eight if they didn't have to
deal with the patriots over the course
of the last decade i think it's fair i
mean i do yeah i mean i look at it that
way you know let alone let's not forget
this aspect too okay this to me this is
a big aspect that sometimes gets looked
over
the dude has coached in the afc north
the afc north
which
i mean other than the patriots the two
best teams in the conference are right
there having to play each other twice a
year the only two teams that really have
consistently at least tried to challenge
the patriots and not be bullied by them
and yeah i mean it hasn't worked out
well for both of them all the time but
at least those two have been there to go
let's get in the ring new england and do
that but hey i mean he's had a deal that
division the ravens you know with ray
lewis still in his prime early on all of
that stuff cincinnati of course with
marvin lewis was very talented really
good for those years i mean he had a
number of years here where we were going
above 500 and there was three teams in
the playoffs from that division like
every year i think that says something
too you know he didn't get some cupcake
easy division where he always knew he
was going to be the king uh that that's
a harder road than what new england had
to deal with with the underwhelming afc
east as we know too but yeah the
patriots have had their number there's
no doubt i mean who haven't the patriots
had the number of
one of the huge challenges for mike
tomlin and the organization over the
course of this next four years that he's
under contract will be to get a
quarterback who can
help the steelers
compete with the ravens the bengals the
browns because the bengals are going to
be better the browns are the browns now
and they're not the browns they used to
be yeah steelers don't get another
franchise quarterback they could get
left in the dust and they could have the
kind of run that would spark major
changes in pittsburgh so quarterback
position next year most likely in the
draft a huge priority to ensure that
this run can continue by the steel
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports